this has to be very weird
when you signed on originally for the
next generation pilot
the the
it is truly amazing that you have you
know the character has landed this you
know you've played this character for so
many years when did it what has it been
like playing someone that has been so
popular with so many star trek fans for
so long you know i i didn't
yes i am disproportionately popular
that's true i did nine episodes
before picard i only did nine episodes
of of q and and it is disproportionately
popular um
uh you know it's very satisfying i mean
there are times which you kind of go
yeah but you know i i really am not i'm
i'm a peripheral
person in in the uh you know in terms of
the the actual hierarchy of things
um and yet there are other times where
where i would enjoy the
uh
fans would say oh and uh you know i
loved it in episode whatever it was when
you came down and you did this and i
learned it like that and i go uh i
wasn't in that episode
yes you were you had to be no i wasn't
it's a character that interestingly
enough has been put into many other
episodes and that i never that i
actually never was in so
it's been a strange in that respect and
and i i don't know i i've enjoyed it
i've enjoyed it i i worked with um with
leonard
nimoy he and i had a company together
called alien voices and uh
you know he told me about how he
struggled with all of that and then
wrote a book called i am not spock and
finally just went oh look you know what
he wrote another book called i am spock
and that was the end of it
yeah um one of the things about picard
uh for season two is that um uh they're
filming season three at the same like
you know right now it's they're filming
season three so i have to ask you is q
a part of both seasons or is it just a
season two thing
i can't
we will not answer to talk about that
okay
i'll say what can you tease for fans
what can you tease about season two and
q's involvement
oh um
well
um it's a different journey
this time
it's it's a journey of higher stakes
by
two characters who have
more to lose
than they have had in the past
and um i i would say that that's a good
uh
indicator of where we're going
on that note i need to stop already i'm
just going to say again thank you so
much for the entertainment and i really
wish you nothing but the best thank you
same to you
you